supernovae are the most powerful
explosions in the universe unleashing
enough energy to outshine galaxies we
have no real metaphor for their power if
the sun were to magically go supernova
it would feel like you were being hit by
the energy of a nuclear explosion every
second for weeks
while supernovae are the engines of
creation forging the elements that
enable life they also burn sterile whole
regions of galaxies so what would happen
if one hit Earth
foreign
there are roughly speaking two ways to
make a supernova either the core of a
massive star implodes or less common a
white dwarf gains Mass to the point
where it ignites explosive nuclear
fusion the outcome is the same a
supernova explosion
when we think of an explosion on Earth
we think of something that happens fast
and ends but a supernova is more like a
volcanic eruption followed by a tsunami
at first there's a colorful ball of hot
expanding gas creating a spectacular
Cloud that will shine for about a month
but then it doesn't stop
hot and dangerous gas rushes outwards at
speeds of 10 000 kilometers a second
through the near vacuum of space
sweeping up the sparse gas of the Galaxy
this wall of gas expands for tens of
thousands of years and will eventually
span up to dozens of light years until
it finally cools off and disperses its
substance back into the Galaxy
so what if this star tsunami hits us
well the damage depends on how far away
it is
stage one thousands of light years away
humans have witnessed dozens of
supernovae but all of them were
thousands of light years away they
appeared as new stars some outshining
the moon twinkling for a few weeks and
disappearing aside from looking very
pretty at this distance they don't do
much to us
stage 2 300 light years away things
begin to get a bit icky once a supernova
occurs around 300 light years away we
can expect one this close to us every
few million years a single star giving
the night sky an eerie glow like
Twilight and while this is far enough
away and dim enough to not do harm to us
they can affect the Earth at these
distances it's like being hit by the
last weak waves of the star tsunami not
strong enough to do real damage but
still noticeable
in fact we know that over the past 10
million years multiple supernovae have
struck Earth from these distances
because we can find radioactive isotopes
of iron deep in the rocks and sediments
at the bottom of the ocean
amazingly these supernovae around the
solar system have cleared a 1 000 light
year wide pocket of space that's called
the local bubble they blew away the
interstellar gas and dust creating a
lumpy wall of gas that's now a cradle
for Star formation
stage 3 150 light years away
once the Supernova happens much closer
than 300 light years we're approaching
the Zone where it does real damage
stars have extremely powerful magnetic
fields when they die the tsunami of dead
star actually retains a lot of this
magnetic energy woven through the shock
wave that expands outwards
in this highly magnetized Cloud we get
conditions like in a huge particle
accelerator that's accelerating charged
particles like protons nuclei and
electrons to immense speeds which means
we have an expanding Cloud that is
shooting deadly radiation in all
directions long after the bright light
from the initial explosion has faded
away
if a supernova happens too close by
waves of these cosmic rays will wash
over the solar system for thousands of
years
while we're mostly protected on Earth's
surface by the atmosphere and ozone
layer the influx of extra radiation will
still increase cancer and mutation rates
not enough to cause a mass extinction
but it will be noticeable
spaceflight would become impossible in
the solar system as astronauts wouldn't
survive the waves of radiation for long
we don't know exactly how bad this would
be but a supernova that is close enough
May trap our species on Earth for
Generations maybe thousands of years it
only gets worse from here
stage four closer than 100 light years
within 100 light years things get bad as
a supernova disrupts our climate in ways
that we don't fully understand yet
there are a few unpleasant things
happening all one after another first
the high energy photons arrive from the
explosion followed by many decades of
radiation from the radioactive tsunami
both of which seriously damaged the
ozone layer Earth's shield against
harmful radiation the ozone layer
absorbs ultraviolet radiation by
breaking apart ozone O3 into O2 and a
free oxygen atom which later reforms
back into another ozone molecule but the
Supernova radiation breaks up nitrogen
molecules that gobble up the free oxygen
breaking the cycle and depleting the
ozone layer quickly
without a radiation Shield everybody
living on the surface is exposed to very
high levels of UV radiation from our sun
cancer rates would Skyrocket and just
going outside during the day could be
life-threatening
the extra radiation would also kill a
lot if not most of the plankton in the
oceans that live near the surface and
are the bases for the marine food chains
leading to a mass extinction
were still Supernova radiation would
ionize gas in the atmosphere which means
that it would punch through molecules
and knock electrons off nuclei leaving
them charged these charged nuclei then
act as seeds for water vapor to gather
and form massive Global clouds in the
worst case they would reflect enough
sunlight to trigger an ice age
in fact it's thought that the Ice Age
two and a half million years ago was
caused by a supernova some scientists
even think that a supernova about 60
light years away might have been the
cause of the devonian mass extinction
350 million years ago but wait there's
more
the electrons punched free by the
radiation form enormous electric
Avalanches or in other words lightning
Earth is hit by some of the worst
thunderstorms in millions of years the
intense lightning causes global
wildfires that consume forests and crops
devastate cities disrupt our electrical
grids and Global Supply chains all while
a decimated ozone layer leaks deadly
radiation
one in the past the ecosystem may have
bounced back from a nearby Supernova
after a few thousand or million years
there's no guarantee modern civilization
can take a hit of this magnitude we
would face food shortages skyrocketing
prices and Wars as Nations struggle to
not be consumed by chaos
so a supernova this close would at the
very least do significant damage for
hundreds or thousands of years if not
and our modern civilization and with it
millions or even billions of lives
still Humanity would likely survive and
could recover
stage five closer than 25 light years
a supernova closer than 25 light years
means that we're in its kill radius
where a mass extinction is all but
guaranteed probably about half of the
ozone layer would be destroyed and
massive climactic disruption on a scale
we've never witnessed would ravage Earth
entire ecosystems would swiftly be wiped
out by radiation AS Global wildfires
enveloped the planet all the things
described before happen but way more
intensely and much faster a few people
might survive for years in bunkers if
they have food supplies but the world
they return to will be devastated and
hostile to life for hundreds of
thousands of years
human extinction is extremely likely
the final stage four light years
being any closer to a supernova is very
unlikely because space is big but the
effects would be extreme even from four
light years away the distance to Alpha
Centauri a supernova would be almost as
bright as the sun in the sky while
casting two Shadows could be fun for a
few hours within days the Earth's
surface gets as hot as a sauna baking
the surface for weeks until the
explosion Fades the surface of Earth
Burns Scout of life even the oceans
aren't safe the massive amount of
radiation that follows Burns away the
ozone layer killing everything that sees
sunlight
it would be the largest Extinction event
in history reducing life to a few
survivors in the deep sea and critters
in the Deep soil life basically has to
start over
conclusion how worried do you need to be
so should you worry no fortunately there
are only a handful of stars that may
explode within one thousand light years
of Earth and none are close enough to be
a serious threat even better these Stars
will probably not go supernova for many
millions of years
so you are safe but there's no guarantee
for the far future as stars orbit the
Galaxy our descendants may find
themselves dangerously close to a
supernova but by then a far more
advanced and wiser Humanity will
hopefully be able to just move out of
the way in any case you can sleep well
tonight under the beautiful night sky
and if you dream about understanding the
physics behind this video and others
we've created a series of lessons to
build your understanding of fundamental
science
made in collaboration with our friends
are brilliant these lessons dive deeper
into topics from our most popular videos
including things like cosmology biology
and even climate science
brilliant is an Interactive Learning
tool that makes science accessible with
a Hands-On approach because we know that
to really learn something you've got to
do it
think of each lesson as a one-on-one
tutoring version of akotskazard video in
our latest lesson you'll Journey further
into the conditions that can trigger a
supernova and how to determine the
impact of one on a planet like ours
brilliant has thousands of lessons to
explore from maths-based topics like
algebra and probability to the concepts
behind machine learning and Quantum
Computing and with new lessons added
each month including ones from kotskazat
you'll always find something fascinating
to learn to get Hands-On with
courtskazat lessons now go to
brilliant.org Nutshell and sign up for
free and with a free trial of brilliant
premium you can explore everything
brilliant has to offer there's even an
extra perk for kotzka's out viewers the
first 200 people to use the link get 20
off their annual membership which
unlocks all of brilliant's courses in
maths science and computer science we'd
love to go above and beyond with our
research brilliant will be the Catalyst
to expand the limits of your knowledge
there are still a few copies left of our
12023 human calendar get it now for a
whole year of joy
[Music]